Zooey Deschanel has been largely
absent from our screens over the
past couple of years - but happily,
it's for several solid reasons.
Here's why you haven't seen Zooey
Deschanel in TV or movies as much lately.
From 2011 to 2018, Zooey Deschanel starred as
Jessica Day - a sweet, quirky teacher who moves
in with three strangers in Los Angeles after a
terrible breakup -- on the hit comedy New Girl.
"Who’s Jess?"
Though the role netted her Emmy
and Golden Globe nominations,
it may have also pigeonholed her as a performer.
There's no question that Jess and Deschanel share
a lot of traits, from their musical talents to
their love of vintage clothing, and early seasons
of New Girl really leaned on those similarities.
The show sharpened a bit in later seasons,
and even poked fun at Jess's highly manicured
quirkiness. Unfortunately, if you didn't invest in
New Girl longterm, you missed all that evolution,
which potentially made her harder to cast in
roles that differed too drastically from Jess.
Between her leading role on New Girl and her
starring turn alongside Joseph Gordon-Levitt
in 500 Days of Summer, the fact is that many of
Deschanel's most high-profile characters fit the
definition of the "Manic Pixie Dream Girl." A term
coined by critic Nathan Rabin after he saw Cameron
Crowe's 2005 film Elizabethtown - specifically,
to address Kirsten Dunst's character - it became
a catchall phrase for quirky female characters,
and unfortunately, Deschanel fit the
stereotype to a T, at least superficially.
For example, 500 Days of Summer's leading
lady, Summer, could best be described as a
Manic Pixie Dream Girl by detractors who
would prefer to ignore the depths of the
character — as well as the strength of
Deschanel's performance - diminishing
Summer to a girl who loves vintage clothes,
is tweely eccentric, and who encourages the
film's male protagonist to make big choices in
his life. Rabin ultimately apologized for even
creating the concept of a Manic Pixie Dream
Girl years later, but the popularity of the
trope - and its backlash - may have affected
Deschanel's opportunities in Hollywood.
Plenty of actors have moved into producing while
still appearing in front of the camera - even
megawatt stars like Brad Pitt, who actually won
his first Academy Award for producing 12 Years
a Slave several years before he won a competitive
Oscar for acting. Zooey Deschanel is no different.
In fact, she moved behind the camera on New Girl
during its run. In 2011, she became a producer,
and from 2014 until the show ended in
2018, also served as an executive producer.
Deschanel also ventured into producing some
other projects throughout her run on New Girl.
Even if she isn't appearing
onscreen, in other words,
there's always a chance Deschanel could produce
again if the right project catches her eye.
Aside from her acting career, one of Zooey
Deschanel's longtime passion projects
has been promoting vegan and vegetarian lifestyles
while helping consumers understand where their
food actually comes from. For multiple seasons,
Deschanel has hosted the webseries Your
Food's Roots, where she talks to farmers,
nutritionists, food historians, and other
experts about how the food you choose affects you
as well as the people around you, larger
communities, and the Earth as a whole.
In fact, working on the show encouraged
Deschanel to become a vegetarian to adopt
more ethical food practices. As she once
explained to People magazine, she learned
so much about where her food was really coming
from, that she began paying more attention.
"The main thing is it's just so hard
to know where meat is coming from.
It's so difficult to know if it was sustainably
raised [or] humanely raised. I really felt like
I couldn't be sure where it was coming from
most of the time. So I stopped eating meat."
Near the height of her career momentum in 2011,
Zooey Deschanel found time to create a place for
women of all ages online. Alongside co-founders
Molly McAleer and Sophia Rossi, Deschanel founded
HelloGiggles just as she landed her starring role
on New Girl. According to HelloGiggles itself,
the site is meant to serve as a, quote, "positive
online community for female-identifying readers,"
and covers everything from beauty
to relationship to finance.
To do this, the site combines personal
essays with news, lists, and columns.
In 2015, Deschanel, McAleer, and Rossi sold
HelloGiggles to Time Inc., but still continued
overseeing the website as it gained an even wider
audience. As Deschanel told the Los Angeles Times
in a statement, the purchase meant the trio and
their staff would be able to reach an even wider
audience through the resources offered by Time.
HelloGiggles is still around to do that today.
In 2015, Zooey Deschanel took on one of the
most important roles of her life - becoming
a mother - with the birth of her first child,
daughter Elsie Wolf. In 2017, with then-husband
Jacob Pechenik, she had a son, Charlie
Wolf, before the couple parted ways in 2019.
In 2018, Deschanel told InStyle that
she was in no rush to return to acting,
preferring to focus on her children.
"I'm just looking for something that would be
exciting and fulfilling for me. I have two kids,
and they're very important to
me. I'm really focused on them,
so I want to make sure that whatever I do next
is really good. It has to be really good
for me to leave them [and go to work]."
By Deschanel's own admission, she's also a
very hands-on parent, as she also told InStyle
"I mean, I'm driving my kids to every class,
every day. I'm there with them all the time.
It's actually rare that I'm not with them. I
try to be there as much as humanly possible."
Ever since New Girl ended in 2018, audiences
haven't seen Zooey Deschanel onscreen
in an acting role. But if you listen closely
to some recent - and huge - children's movies,
you'll be able to hear her distinctive
voice. Live-action acting might be on hold,
but voice acting is still a part
of Deschanel's working life.
In 2016, Deschanel began appearing in the
enormously successful Trolls franchise,
voicing Bridget, a member of the
antagonistic Bergen race. However,
Bridget is a particularly sweet Bergen, harboring
a secret crush on the Prince of the Bergens,
Gristle Jr., and working as a
scullery maid in the palace.
"You love Gristle, too? You
better back off, girlfriend."
After the first film, Deschanel returned not
only for the much-anticipated 2020 sequel
Trolls World Tour, which marked
her first acting gig since 2017,
but she also appeared in NBC's Trolls Holiday
special, reprising her role as Bridget in both
projects. Whether it's to cater to her children
or just because voice work is a fun gig for
major actors to play with, Deschanel is clearly
doing well with her work in the Trolls movies.
Even throughout the highest highs of her film
and television career, Zooey Deschanel always
kept her true passion project, the band She &
Him, alive. Alongside partner M. Ward, the duo
has released several albums, and with Deschanel
on piano, vocals, and ukulele and Ward on guitar,
the two strike a decidedly folksy sound.
They've been quite successful, releasing
2008's Volume One, 2010's Volume Two, 2013's
Volume Three and A Very She & Him Christmas,
2014's Classics, and 2016's Christmas Party.
Between albums, Ward and Deschanel also play live;
as recently as 2019, the two were still doing
holiday tours, visiting several cities during
the season to spread musical cheer. In fact,
during their 2019 Christmas Party tour, Deschanel
was spotted bringing her famous boyfriend,
Property Brother Jonathan Scott, on stage
during a show at the Met in Philadelphia.
After meeting during a taping of Carpool
Karaoke in 2019, Zooey Deschanel and HGTV star
and Property Brother Jonathan Scott started
dating, and over time, the two slowly made
their relationship public. Throughout several
cute Instagram posts and other milestones,
Deschanel and Scott have opened
up about their relationship,
and in December of 2020, Deschanel put in an
appearance alongside Scott on his home network.
Deschanel appeared in an episode of the HGTV
series Celebrity IOU, which sees celebrities
do special construction and renovations favors
for friends and loved ones via the hosting and
producing powers of the Property Brothers. In this
sweet installment, Deschanel helps out a longtime
friend - Sarah, who has been a part of her life
since kindergarten — by expanding her home into
an open-space concept. Beyond Deschanel's
amazing gesture, it's even cuter knowing that
she's appearing alongside Scott, her real-life
partner, and supporting his television ventures.
Zooey Deschanel's blunt bangs,
"adorkable" personality,
and ukulele-fueled indie band have
made her an easily spoofable celebrity
over the years. Now that she's out of the
spotlight, Deschanel is poking fun at herself,
and even appeared in a music video alongside
Katy Perry to reference a long-running joke.
There's no denying that Deschanel
and Perry look eerily similar,
to the point where Perry even admitted
that she occasionally pretended to be
Deschanel to gain access to exclusive events
and clubs. Finally, in December of 2020, the duo
made light of their similarity when Deschanel
starred in the music video for Perry's song
"Not the End of the World," one of the
singles from her Smile album. In the video,
Deschanel plays an unsuspecting human who finds
herself held captive by aliens who really,
really like Katy Perry, and even try to get
Deschanel's character to perform as the pop
star. It's a bit that perfectly capitalizes on the
constant claims that the two stars are lookalikes.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.